good morning take it to Wednesday I have
is it so big that when I get close to
the camcorder my camcorder believes that
my zit is a face I mean frankly Hank
this is it is so big that I've begun to
wonder whether it's going to develop
self consciousness and because of that
I've been thinking about conjoined twins
so I got thought I would one up your top
5 video from Monday and give you top 6
pairs of conjoined twins in history
which is actually not to brag or
anything kind of a top 12 number 6 the
bit ndon maids Mary Ann Eliza chokers
were conjoined twins who have five plots
of land when they died to benefit the
poor of their town binden and for the
last 500 years continuing up to today
every Easter there's lots of stuff for
the poor people in this town thanks to
Mary and Eliza in addition to like bread
and cheese and stuff pensioners and
widows also get bid ndon cakes which are
these like massively disgusting biscuits
printed with conjoined twins on them
like one 19th century historian referred
to them as not by any means tempting
anyway Haig let that be a lesson to you
if you leave your money to charity they
will print your face on disgusting
biscuits forever but if you leave your
money to your brother he will spend it
number-5 Giacomo and Giovanni Tocci
Giacomo and Giovanni were conjoined
twins with two heads four arms and two
legs and like a lot of conjoined twins
they spent pretty much their entire
childhood on the freakshow circuit in
fact the Tochi twin spent like five
years touring America during which time
Mark Twain heard about them which
inspired him to write those
extraordinary twins and also inspired
indirectly the great novel Pudd'nhead
Wilson so basically without the Tochi
twins Mark Twain is a lesser novelist
see and people say that the history of
conjoined twin de Miz not interesting
stop looking at my zit number four Lauri
and George Chappell who are still living
and who despite sharing 30% of their
brain matter have very different lives
Laurie works part-time at a hospital
laundry George is a professional country
singer by the way they're both female
all conjoined twins are identical it's
like an autonomous region of John Green
number 3 Jodie and Mary not their real
name so in 2000 conjoined twins were
born in the United Kingdom Jodie and
Mary Jodie was the stronger of the two
twins her heart basically pumped for
Mary's blood system Mary was a separate
person with a separate brain but she
couldn't survive without Jodie doctors
determined that both twins would
inevitably die unless they were
separated but if they were separated
Mary would die immediately Mary and
Jodi's parents didn't want them to be
separated but a court ordered the
procedure as expected married
Jody survived and in fact is still alive
today and the case raised all kinds of
difficult questions about personhood and
medical ethics a discussion that I'm
sure will continue in the comments
number two Chang and Aang the stars of
this great book God's fool Chang and Eng
with the original Siamese twins they had
a crazy life that started in Thailand
and took them all around the world they
eventually bought a tobacco plantation
in North Carolina married sisters and
had 21 kids between the two of them like
a lot of the non separated conjoined
twins were talking about they had a
fascinating and very rich life that in
some ways was probably better than it
would have been if they'd been born
Singleton's which by the way Hank is the
word for people who aren't conjoined
like you know us and most people this
takes me and my favourite conjoined
twins of all time million Kristine McCoy
who were known as the two-headed
nightingale Millie and Christine were
born into slavery in 1851 sold
repeatedly taken away from their mother
eventually kidnapped by a guy who toured
them around the world while beating them
they were eventually taken back by one
of their owners and reunited with their
biological mother and the slave owner
and his wife taught million Christine
how to speak five languages and how to
sing in perfect harmony but also owned
them as property and took all their
money but then when they were 13 the
Emancipation Proclamation freed them and
they went on to work sideshows and with
Barnum and Bailey and made a ton of
money certainly million Christine were
exploited throughout their lives but
it's hard to say that their lives would
be better if they'd been separated at
birth and that's really what fascinates
me about conjoined twins we're so
obsessed with the idea that unusual
anatomies need to be made normal that we
forget that unusual Anatomy is can have
many advantages that's not to say the
conjoining this is entirely desirable
just that the reality of conjoining
realities resists simplicity lastly
nerdfighters as I'm sure you're aware
they've been devastating floods in
Queensland Australia there is a link in
the doobly-doo to help people who've
been affected by those floods don't
forget to be awesome Hank I will see you
on Friday